[Musique]
il était une fois un monde bleu tout
était bleu sauf 1.1 point rose c'est
ainsi que ma fille carla marie se
décrivait dans une histoire qu'elle
écrivit et illustra à 9 ans un point
rose d'étonnant dans le monde bleu de la
vie et détonante elle les précoces
hypersensible d'une vitalité débordante
toujours prête à s'émerveiller à aider
les autres et avoir dans l'amour la
cause fondamentale de toute chose un
amour si fusionnelle que toutes nos
séparations se vivent comme une
déchirure et en conclusion de son
histoire elle dit finalement elle était
bien dans son bleu et ali vécu très
heureuse et nous vivons très heureux
dans son bleu son papa sa soeur et moi
jusqu'au 22 octobre 2014
ce jour là notre vie bascule les
urgences pédiatriques du chu de la
timone décèle une lésion du tronc
cérébral sur l'irm qui l'ont pratiqué
sur carla marie il nous annonce qu'on
doit passer la nuit pour faire des
examens complémentaires
les examens sont rassurants concluant à
une simple origines inflammatoires avant
de conclure deux mois plus tard un glee
en infiltrant du tronc cérébral une
tumeur de l'enfant inopérables incurable
très agressive ne lui laissant une
espérance de vie que de dhuisy mois au
mieux est certainement beaucoup moins
carla marie devient alors pour le milieu
médical
un cas perdu 1,4 tellement difficile à
vivre que tout le monde aimerait déjà
l'oublier comme un échec
deux mois plus tard carla marie s'éteint
dans la nuit à 1h du matin à l'hôpital
après deux mois d'hospitalisation
un quart d'heure après son dernier
souffle le médecin de garde bien
constater le décès sans un mot sans un
regard
et on nous demande si on a prévu la
tenue
je ne comprends pas ses mots quelle
tenue aurais-je dû prévoir les parents
ne prévoit jamais la mort de leur enfant
jusqu'au dernier souffle ils espèrent le
miracle à laurent labit de mes vêtements
et puis on nous annonce que les
brancardiers vont venir la chercher pour
la conduire au funérarium
nous devrons attendre huit heures pour
la revoir ensuite on reste un moment
immobile incrédule avec son papa dans la
chambre après que les brancardiers des
temps menés sur leur chariot puis la
porte s'ouvre et on nous demande un peu
gêné et poliment de combien de temps on
a besoin pour rassembler nos affaires
avant l'équipe de relève de cinq heures
pour refaire la chambre alors on quitte
la chambre on regarde une dernière fois
le nom écrit sur la porte aux fenêtres
weleda et on attend dehors sur un banc
l'ouverture du funérarium alors à la
souffrance indicible de la perte de
notre fille s'ajoute un sentiment
d'abandon
notre fille n'a manqué de rien d'un
point de vue médical
elle a même eu droit à un traitement
exceptionnel mais est-ce juste de
médical dont on a besoin
quand on vit la fin de vie de son enfant
l'hôpital
ce n'est pas un lieu fait pour mourir
pour personne et encore moins pour un
enfant il existe un décalage entre ce
qui se joue pour des parents et pour le
personnel soignant les priorités ne sont
pas les mêmes pour les parents c'est se
donner en accéléré tout l'amour que
toute une vie ne suffirait pas à se
donner pour le personnel soignant c'est
vivre au plus vite et oublier ceux qui
ne perçoivent que comme souffrances et
échec
pourtant les derniers mois passés auprès
de carla marie ont été les plus dures de
toute notre existence mais aussi les
plus forts les plus intenses ce qui se
jouait était si fort en termes d'amour
que parfois c'était même comme d'un
autre monde
c'était un océan d'amour qui réussissait
à prendre le pas sur toute l'horreur de
la situation et c'est aussi ce que
rapporte beaucoup de professionnels de
soins palliatifs qui parle d'un
enrichissement réciproque de moments de
vie ultime est beau au chevet des
patients en fin de vie
pourtant il n'existe pas d'unité de
soins palliatifs en pédiatrie dans nos
hôpitaux français et les centres de
soins palliatifs existants sont
réticents quand ils ne refusent pas
d'accueillir des enfants n'existe pas
d'accompagnement des familles vivent ces
épreuves ni de soutien au personnel
soignant tout aussi durement éprouvé
aucun accompagnement à la mesure du
cataclysme que représente la fin de vie
d'un enfant ni aucune prise en charge à
la mesure de l'amour ultime qui se joue
dans ces moments là
pourtant un enfant décède tous les jours
du cancer en france et on compte plus de
4000 décès parents d'enfants ce que l'on
se représente comme la chose la plus
inconcevable
la perte la plus inconcevable frappe
donc 4000 familles par an alors pourquoi
ne nous ne les accompagne ont pas mieux
et pourquoi ce vide parce que la mort
d'un enfant et si impensable qu'elle est
un penser parce que sitôt arrivé le
meilleur moyen que l'on trouve pour y
faire face c'est de l'oublier pourtant
les conséquences de la mort d'un enfant
doivent être pensées parce qu'elles sont
une réalité et qu'elle touche un cercle
bien plus large que les seuls parents
les fratries souvent sur plusieurs
générations
les camarades de classe les enseignants
de l'enfant tout le personnel soignant
personne ne sort indemne de ce véritable
traumatisme
et pourtant tout le monde essaie de
faire comme si cela n'était pas arrivé
ou n'arrivaient pas alors les parents
vivent la double peine de la perte de
leur enfant et du déni ils se sentent
dérangeant fui et presque honteux parce
qu'il est honteux de vivre un tel destin
parce que forcément doit être un peu
maudit pour ainsi être frappé par la
fatalité
parce qu'on fait peur et parce qu'on
rappelle à nous mêmes chaque fois ce que
tout le monde voudrait oublier la mort
possible d'un enfant alors non seulement
n'accompagne pas les parents mais en
plus quelques mois après le décès notre
société intime aux parents de faire le
deuil comme une invitation à passer à
autre chose a tourné la page
à prendre sur soi aménager les autres
mais de qui se soucie ton vraiment quand
on encourage un parent à faire le deuil
de l' équilibre psychique du parent ou
de soi même qui a le plus intérêt à
oublier cette mort contre nature le
parent condamné à vivre avec ou son
entourage qui aimerait ne plus y penser
pour retrouver son insouciance d'avant
alors si faire le deuil de dire oublier
c'est juste impossible pour des parents
parce qu après la perte de leur enfant
le plus difficile et le plus
insupportable c'est son oubli alors
quelles ressources apportées à ces
familles
comment les aider sans se mettre soi
même en danger parce qu'on est tous
démunis face à un tel malheur on a tous
la tentation de la fuite
parce qu'on ne sait pas quoi dire parce
qu'on a peur d'être maladroit parce que
on a peur de pas être à la hauteur
mais la maladresse n'est rien à côté de
la fuite qui sera forcément vécue par
les parents comme un déni de leurs
malheurs il faut oser en parler pour
sortir les parents de leur isolement et
pour s'aider soi-même à vivre ce que
l'on veut pas vivre
mais que dire
en vérité il s'agit moins de dire que
d'écouter montrer de la considération
pour l'enfant en fin de vie parce que la
fin de vie c'est encore de la vie et de
la vie ultime montrer de la
considération pour les parents pour le
malheur qui est le leur sans les fuir
sans faire comme si de rien n'était être
là juste présent et bienveillant alors
quelles ressources apportées aux parents
et bien la reconnaissance d'abord
ensuite l'amour parce que l'amour est
bien la ressource ultime pour vivre la
fin de vie d'un enfant et lui survivre
après l'amour des autres bien sûr mais
aussi l'amour de son enfant encore et
toujours
parce que la mort de l'enfant ce n'est
pas la fin de la vie ni surtout la fin
de la vie avec lui pour la famille les
enfants les parents perdent leurs
enfants mais pas l'amour de leurs
enfants qui continuent à vivre en eux
alors acceptant que même si l'enfant
n'est plus les parents continuent à en
parler à lui faire une place sans les
fuir sans les jugés dérangeants et
dérangeant ils le sauront forcément en
parlant de leur enfant défunt en
partageant ses photos en fêtant son
anniversaire en faisant de son lieu de
sépulture en lieu plein de couleurs mais
il ne faut pas y voir un comportement
pathologique et mortifère mais bien
plutôt un lien d'amour qui perdure au
delà de la mort ce lien
c'est bien la clé de la résilience faire
une place à l'enfant pour qu'il ne
prenne pas toute la place
c'est l'enjeu de l'accompagnement des
familles orpheline d'un enfant je me
répète souvent comme un mantra une
phrase que carla marie m'a dit un jour à
8 ans elle m'a dit maman derrière chaque
malheur se cache un petit bonheur et
bien derrière le grand malheur de la
perte d'un enfant se cache ce petit
bonheur de l'amour plus fort que la mort
un jour quelqu'un m'a dit que mon
histoire lui donner décuplé son envie de
vivre et partager
et bien c'est soit que l'on s'expose en
s'ouvrant à nous parents orphelins d'un
enfant non pas parce que notre malheur
vous aidera à vous sentir chanceux de
votre propre bonheur ou absence de
malheur mais parce que vous puiserez
dans le vé notre vécu de ce malheur
l'immense espoir d'un amour plus fort
que la mort
six mois après le décès de carla marie
nous avons créé l'association le point
rose pour développer les soins
palliatifs pédiatriques pour accompagner
les personnes confrontées à la fin de
vie d'un enfant pour les aider à vivre
ces moments d'amour ultime à son chevet
et à trouver une forme de résilience
après dans l'amour un point rose
pour trouver les petits bonheurs
derrière le grand malheur un point rose
pour ajouter de la vie au jour quand on
ne peut ajouter deux jours à la vie pour
rendre le bleu autour plus bleu est plus
profond pour décupler envie de vivre et
partager